they're putting you two in charge  just kidding it's laughter we're after  you're no longer hiring scary  and scarers are out jokesters are in  report to mift what exactly is miffed uh  now you've done it  the monsters inc facilities  if a machine needs maintenance we  maintain it now  nobody saw nothing well nobody saw  nothing  they're putting you two in charge  just kidding it's laughter we're after  you're no longer hiring scariest  scarers are out jokesters are in report  to mift what exactly is  ah now you've done it the monsters inc  facilities tame  if a machine needs maintenance we  maintain it now  yeah nobody saw nothing well nobody saw  nothing